Speaker 1: Hey, this is really interesting
news out of Texas.
Actor Matthew McConaughey or McConaughey,
as some people like to say, is polling 12
points ahead of Republican Texas Governor
Greg Abbott.
He's not running.
If your reaction was I didn't know that he
was running, he's not.
This is a new poll from the Dallas Morning
News and the University of Texas, Tyler.
It's based on 1100 registered voters, 30 percent
Democrats, 37 percent Republicans, 33 percent
who are neither 45 percent of voters say they
would support Matthew McConaughey over Greg
Abbott if Matthew McConaughey were to run
for governor.
33 percent said they'd support Abbott over
McConaghy, 22 percent say they would vote
for someone else or aren't really sure.
This is interesting because McConaghy has
actually kind of teased and alluded to maybe
running in the state of Texas.
He is not confirmed.
He told CNBC last month he is not joking.
He said, quote, I'm not teasing the idea.
I'm actually looking at the idea and giving
it serious consideration.
I have a new chapter for myself personally
in my life.
I believe it's some sort of leadership role.
I don't know what the role is.
I don't know my category.
We've been talking about the why of leadership
and even I would say we need some more good
leaders.
This would be fascinating.
So there's two parts to this.
I don't know how much this says about Matthew
McConaughey specifically.
What I mean by that is Greg Abbott has so
mismanaged almost everything.
I mean, the pandemic, the power outage and
grid, the electrical grid situation, he's
a complete and total clown who doesn't seem
to care much about the health or safety or
welfare of people in Texas.
It's possible a random school teacher with
no name recognition would maybe do OK against
Greg Abbott.
So part of it is we have to figure out how
much of it is Matthew Matthew McConaughey
specifically.
But then you add in the fact that if you look
at Matthew McConaughey over the last 12 to
18 months, I've been seeing him doing more
and more conversations and interviews with
people in the political space.
He does actually seem interested.
He seems to be taking this seriously.
I don't know the guy's politics.
I have no idea whether he's a Democrat or
a Republican.
I don't know anything about him.
What I do know, though, is that.
He at least doesn't seem like a radical right
winger if he is a centrist or further left,
and if without even announcing a candidacy,
he is doing this well in Texas, what we saw
in twenty twenty in Texas, the tightening
in Texas for Trump in his reelection campaign,
which ultimately didn't end up being that
close, but it was could it could have been
a much, much bigger margin for Donald Trump.
This could signal significant changes in the
state of Texas.
And we are all we can do is continue to follow
it.
We've been talking about it before.
Georgia and Texas have been the ones that
we've been watching relatively closely.
Very interesting.
And we're going to keep a close eye on that.